الجارديان نشرت مقالا لرئيسه قسم الصحه
العامه العالميه في جامعه ادنبرا تقول فيه
انها لم يسبق ان رات المنظمات الصحيه تشعر
بالقلق كما هو الحال في غزه منبهه الى ان
ربع سكان غزه معرضون للموت في غضون عام
بسبب تفشي الامراض الناجمه عن هذا الصراع
غير المسبوق كما
[موسيقى]
تصفه في صحيفه واشنطن بوست يلاحظ تقرير ان
كشف الجيش الاسرا الي عن نتائج تحقيقين
شدد التركيز على واحده من اكثر الحروب
تدميرا خلال قرن التحقيق الاول مرتبط
بحادث قتل الرهائن الثلاثه وكان يمكن
تجنبه اما الثاني فيتعلق بقتل عشرات
المدنيين في مخيم المغازي قالت اسرائيل
بشانه ان نوع الذخيره لم يكن متناسبا مع
طبيعه الهدف يستنتج التقرير ان التحقيق
يعالجان اكثر نقطتين جلبت الادانه دوليا و
محليا للهجوم الاسرائيلي حمايه المدنيين
وتامين اطلاق الرهائن
[موسيقى]
نشرت صحيفتها ارتس مقابله اجرتها مع
المؤرخ الاسرائيلي موشي زيمرمان قال
خلالها ان هجوم حماس اظهر فشل الصهيونيه
لا يعتبر زيمرمان الصهيونيه حلا لليهود
ويبرر طرحه بان الشعب اليهودي اليوم يعيش
حاله انعدام تام للامن ثم يقترح ان يكون
حل الدولتين نتيجه للصراع القائم بين
الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين عدا ذلك لا حل واقعيا
بالنسبه لزمر
مان في مجله فورين افيرز يرى مقال ان
اسرائيل ما كانت لتتمكن من تتبع اهدافها
الحربيه المعلنه في غزه بحريه كما تفعل
اليوم لولا الدعم الامريكي وبالتالي فهي
تملك اسبابا قويه للحفاظ على تحالفها
الرئيسي لتحقيق ذلك يتعين على اسرائيل ان
تحدد الطريقه التي تخطط من خلالها لتسويه
صراعها مع الفلسطينيين الى الابد وتعالج
مشاكلها السياسيه
الداخليه يدعو احرونوت نجد فيها ان ايران
تعمل على تسريع نقل الاسلحه الدقيقه الى
حزب الله استعدادا لصراع واسع النطاق
الصحيفه اوضحت ان ايران تسرع عمليه تسليم
الصواريخ والقذائف عبر سوريا وتحاول ايضا
نقل انظ دفاع ضد المروحيات والطائرات
المسيره
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيليه